pour parler des galères des stagiaires
c'est souvent cindy qu'invite les
journalistes de télévision
ancienne étudiante en graphisme
elle est devenue célèbre depuis qu'elle
a publié une bd sur ses mésaventures de
stagiaires
aujourd'hui elle participe à une
émission de télévision avec norman un
jeune comique de la génération internet
les stages à répétition lui aussi il
connaît sa [__] j'ai connu comme un
ouf on l'a fait sans doute et la peur du
temps je me suis fait virer sauf le
dernier ou au final je me suis barré
d'accord c'est peut-être ce que j'aurais
dû faire des fois je vous dit m'baré
carrément sur le plateau cindy vient
d'assurer la promotion de sa bd qu'elle
considère comme un acte militant aux
normes alors aisé citoyens des combats à
mener
oui voilà c'est un combat entre
guillemets parce que bon je fais mes
illustrations mais bon je les fais pas
non plus avec le poing levé c'est c'est
aussi pour pour montrer ce qui ne va pas
dans l'amitié à 25 ans cindy se retrouve
propulsé sur le devant de la scène
bien loin de son quotidien de stagiaires
que nous avions filmé il y a deux ans à
l'époque
cindy avait accepté de témoigner mais
anonymement pour ne pas compromettre son
avenir professionnel
nous avions masquer son visage est
l'avion rebaptisé emilie emilie 23 ans
diplômé en bts multimédia
depuis quatre mois elle est stagiaire
graphiste dans une grande agence de
publicité du centre de paris
elle enchaîne les stages depuis deux ans
elle en a effectué cinq dans cinq
agences différentes et à la clé toujours
pas d'emploi emilie vite en banlieue une
heure de trajet qui s'ajoutent à deux
grosses journées de travail
je suis
assistante du directeur de création pas
pour moi c'est pas du travail de singer
moi c'est vraiment un travail de
salagnac on peut finir très d'art c'est
souvent je peux j'ai fini à 22h 23h
si je travaille autant
en gros c'est pour montrer que j'en veux
que je suis motivé que que j'ai envie de
rester dans cette boîte avec son
indemnité de stage 417 euros mensuels
cindy ne pouvait pas se payer
d'appartement elle vivait toujours chez
ses parents qui commençait à s'inquiéter
pour son avenir
tel un jour on s'installe on a un
appartement sont fait sa vie de famille
c'est pas possible on la sent un petit
peu pas bien dans sa peau pour ça que
vous avez fait des stages ça n'existait
pas avant lui bloquer ce trajet lors de
notre tournage cindy racontait ses
galères de stagiaires sur internet
si c'est quelqu'un qui dit alain
stagiaires de venir travailler à samedi
et celle ci répond non et là surprise il
s'agira dit non donc les stagiaires sont
là ils viennent tous s'inclinent au
l'assagir toi qui osé de dire vraiment
nous admirons c'est finalement grâce à
ses dessins qu'elle a pu tirer un trait
sur sa vie d'étudiante
après la diffusion de notre reportage
cindy a été repéré par un éditeur il a
publié sa première bd mois 20 ans
diplômée motivée exploiter un succès
commercial
dix mille exemplaires vendus en quelques
mois et des fans qui se bousculent pour
obtenir une dédicace de cindy je pensais
pas que ça allait m'arriver est vraiment
faim lorsque j'arrêterai dédicacer la bd
ou où j'ai voyagé j'ai mis tout ce que
j'avais
dedans tout ce que j'ai enduré et donc
moi je suis contente
c'est inattendu aussi pour elle c'est
l'occasion de constater que ces
mésaventures sont toujours d'actualité
que j'ai six stages et en ce moment
petit dessin encourageant je pense qu'on
est tous dans la même galère
il y en a pour la chance de pouvoir
vérifier leurs parents mais il y en a
qui doivent gérer un loyer
se trouvait à bouffer tout seul et la g1
fisc 27 ans quand il a fait plein de
stage dans le cadre de ses études
quand il a eu terminé on lui a proposé
des stages même si c'est vraiment très
difficile pour cette génération là
chemin depuis
cindy a publié un second album consacré
cette fois aux problèmes du logement
chez les étudiants cette génération qui
peine aujourd'hui à entrer dans la vie
active n'a pas fini de l'inspirer
au début des recherches de stage il y as
souvent internet et ses millions de
petites annonces plus ou moins
alléchante plus ou moins légales aussi
ballantyne 25 ans est membre de
génération précaire
un collectif d'étudiants qui agit
généralement masqué nous lui avons
demandé de nous aider à décrypter
certaines offres posté par des
entreprises qui nous semblait suspecte
donc le secteur btp construction
immobilier bon ok fonction assistant
marketing démarrage au plus tôt durée
supérieure à deux mois donc là moi qui
connaît bien ce genre de truc ça veut
dire direct dans ma tête ça doit être
rémunérés au minimum un tiers du smic
type de contrat stage conventionné
hockey rémunération non rémy n'a donc là
en deux lignes sa valise et tout le
reste ça a rendu cette annonce
complètement mais complètement abusive
autre exemple d'annoncer clairement
illégale cette fois dans l'hôtellerie
pour les vacances un établissement
recherche une stagiaire à la fois
réceptionniste et femme de chambre est
serveuse emplois saisonniers alors ça il
ya moi j'ai en gros pour l'un avec les
emplois saisonniers donc dans la loi en
gros il est dit de mémoire un stage ne
doit pas répondre à un besoin lié à un
accroissement temporaire de l'activité
je crois que c'est exactement ça la loi
donc un accroissement temporaire
d'activité
or par principe un emploi saisonnier ça
veut dire que c'est temporaire etc ces
saisonniers
donc ça correspond à un moment dans
l'année où il ya un accroissement
temporaire d'activité
donc je ne vois pas comment on peut
proposer ça un stage c'est pas possible
c'est inégal complètement illégal en
théorie les stages doivent permettre aux
étudiants de valider une partie de leur
cursus ou de se frotter à la dure
réalité du monde du travail
mais ce n'est pas toujours le cas loin
de là
on a des difficultés financières dans
une entreprise et donc au lieu de
réduire la voilure
on va élargir la voilure m'avez démontré
plus faire plus précaires ce qui est
complètement abusif
il faut dire que payer un étudiant coûte
beaucoup moins cher que d'embaucher un
salarié
l'indemnité de stage légal représente un
tiers du smic et les nets de charges
certains employeurs en usent voir on
abuse et ne s'en cachent même pas sur
internet une entreprise a retenu notre
attention
elle propose des dizaines de stage en
tous genres mécanicien webmaster
commercial c'est sur le marché de
morlaix que nous avons retrouvé l'homme
qui a poster toutes ces annonces
ça va être assez dur sur le marché ça un
poney mécanique des échasses
rebondissantes c'est le genre de produit
atypique que commercialise raimu
aujourd'hui avec son équipe
cette opération promotionnelle en
échasses bonjour c'est nouveau ça arrive
ça arrive à mort né pour aller chercher
les frites c'est très bien et pour faire
la peinture pour faire les patients dans
la société de rémy le plus curieux
ce ne sont pas ces drôles des chasses
mais plutôt le statut de sa trentaine de
collaborateurs tous des stagiaires
nous l'avions rencontré il ya deux ans
rémy venait de créer sa société et
vivait chez sa mère son garage lui
servait de siège social et d'entrepôts
donc évincé là où c'est là les locaux de
l'entreprise
c'est là où l'on propose maintenant les
différents produits sportifs rémy ne
dispose pas de locaux pour les
livraisons il utilise un camion acheté à
la casse à l'époque le chef d'entreprise
était un adepte du système d pour éviter
toute dépense vélo aujourd'hui pour moi
je viens de démarrer un salarié ça va
représenter une charge qui est beaucoup
trop importante pour moi donc je n'ai
pas salarié je me suis entouré de
personnes de stagiaires qui recherche
d'expérience et ça de l'expérience je
peux en donner
mais rémy a conscience de profiter d'un
système controversé vous dis pas arrangé
à vue un peu d'un système on est à la
limite de la légalité a aujourd'hui je
prends certains stagiaires qui ne sont
pas rémunérés alors qu'ils devraient
être rémunérés
rémy risque une amende mais les
contrôles de l'inspection du travail
sont très rares
depuis la diffusion de notre reportage
il ya deux ans le jeune patron n'a
jamais reçu la visite de l'inspection du
travail et cela ne semble ni l'inquiéter
neil étonné pourtant il continue à
n'employer que des stagiaires sans les
indemniser il ya un inspecteur du
travail pour tellement beaucoup
d'entreprises et des entreprises où il
ya des problèmes
moi ya pas de problème si les exploiter
ces nouveaux stagiaires
j'ai vraiment mais vraiment pas j'ai
vraiment pas l'impression d exploiter
j'ai conscience que je suis pas dans la
légalité
par contre j'ai pas du tout la
pression'' espère le patron dit avoir la
conscience tranquille parce qu'il a
l'impression de proposer une formule
attractive à ses stagiaires
une formule qui va bien au delà d'une
première expérience professionnelle
aujourd'hui il a déménagé les locaux de
son entreprise dans cette ferme bretonne
dont il est propriétaire
c'est ici qu'il vit au quotidien avec
une dizaine de ses stagiaires
on a fait aussi avec les moyens du bord
alors attention parce que donc là on est
en train justement de mettre
l'électricité donc je vous faire voir
cette cette caravane est donc celle là
la particularité d'avoir été refaite
justement par une stagiaire qui est en
décoration d'intérieur
une déco à moindre coût peut-être pour
faire oublier que le confort des
stagiaires reste sommaire ce qui est
aussi sympa et là on en parle avec avec
sourire quand vous voyez y a pas de
toilettes
donc voilà les les stagiaires qui
viennent on leur propose un saut comme
comme dans l'ancien temps alors au
départ une stagiaire sont stupéfaits un
sommet on attend en vie dessous
je peux vous dire que le deuxième jour
jarre le prodige au fn pas le deuxième
jour ouais ils prennent pas ce que s'il
pleut quand il fait tempête à 3 heures
du matin je peux vous dire qu'ils
préfèrent le logement dans les trois
caravanes acheté d'occasion est
rudimentaire
les plus chanceux dorment dans une
yourte au fond du jardin loger les
s'agir de rémy sont aussi nourries au
moment des repas le stage prend des airs
de colonies de vacances les jeunes font
la cuisine à tour de rôle avec un budget
limité
je voulais juste dire qu'il y avait deux
kilos de carottes à 1 euro le kilo
ça fait deux euros il ya deux autres
euros de deux autres routes
d'ingrédients donc là on est en train de
manger pour 4 euros et on est onze à
manger ce qui fait que l' on mange quand
même que pour 45 centimes ce qui est pas
mal quand même
après le déjeuner les jeunes recrues de
rémy repasse au salon pour se mettre au
travail sur leur ordinateur personnel
ils sont informaticiens responsable des
ressources humaines commerciaux parmi
eux zul qui à 20 ans pour valider son
année à l'université de nancy
elle avait besoin d'un stage qu'elle ne
trouvait pas faute de mieux
c'est cher et mikel a atterri
on a quand même beaucoup tous chercher
de stage et on a toujours eu de refus
soit pas de repères tout court donc je
remercie rémi aujourd'hui d'ailleurs
accepté en stage dans ces pays en plus
du travail de bureau
les stagiaires de rémy doivent se
montrer polyvalent leur patron les
emplois aussi pour la rénovation de son
corps de ferme
ils appellent ça les tâches communes
elle représente deux heures et demie de
travail chaque jour
voilà pourquoi on tenait à
l'informaticien est obligé de lâcher sa
souris pour jouer de la pioche ce assez
tranchées qu'on a fait pour passer des
dégâts nés explique en fait pour amener
l'électricité proprement dans toutes les
dépendances et en piochant selon qu on a
appris en tenant à 20 ans dans sa yourte
il nous confie qu'il apprécie beaucoup
ce stage au grand air et un peu des
tâches ingrates on doit piocher doit
entretenir la propriété et tout ça mais
après moi ça personnellement ça me
dérange pas et ça ça ça ravive un peu
l'esprit d'équipé de communauté du lieu
et ses fins et c'est génial cours c'est
complètement différente de ce que
j'aurais pu vivre dans une entreprise
classique avec un bureau tout ça après
depuis la diffusion de notre précédent
reportage
la société engranger ses premiers
bénéfices 8000 euros l'année dernière
mais toujours pas la moindre embauche à
l'horizon pour les jeunes recrues de
rythme le petit bénéfice qu'on a pu
faire
l'année passée on l'a justement
réinvestis dans des caravanes dans une
yourte justement pour un meilleur
confort des étudiants et pour faire
venir les étudiants qui sont ici vous
allez fais donc
l'an dernier vous êtes pas dit je vais
embaucher quelqu'un pour l'instant on
peut pas encore faut il faut compter à
peu près mon salaire maintenant ça va
être à peu près 1000 le 1200 euros non
chargées moi ça va vous coûter dont 3000
euros à peu près par mois et donc par an
il faut que je trouve 36000 euros à
aujourd'hui je ne salarie pas encore
juste même moi je suis pas salarié donc
pour l'instant on ne peut pas encore
parler d'eux
d'embauché d'embaucher quelqu'un depuis
la création de sa société
rémy et fait travailler plus de 200
stagiaires à l'entendre cette main
d'oeuvre gratuite l'aiderait tout juste
assurer la survie de son entreprise
un argument que les enseignes de
distribution
elle aussi très consommatrice de
stagiaires ne peuvent pas invoquer nous
l'avions constaté dans notre dernier
reportage lors des soldes à paris une
période où les magasins font massivement
appel aux stagiaires
une de nos journaliste s'était fait
passer pour une cliente dans la boutique
d'une grande marque de prêt-à-porter
on joue pas je regarde quand une femme
parmi les vendeurs
elle n'avait eu aucun mal à trouver les
stagiaires il était partout mais d'agir
sans voir qu'ils ont d'eux dans le monde
aucune pression c'est pour ça qu'ils
nourrissent a varié entre hackers on
n'est même pas pays on n'a rien d'un
cadeau elle est chez soi qu'on m'avait
est un vendeur pas comme un must à gien
exploités
à l'époque l'enseigne avait refusé de
nous accorder une interview et s'était
contenté de nous faire parvenir un mail
de démentis voici la déclaration que
nous pouvons vous communiquer les
boutiques de notre marque en france
offre une voire très occasionnellement
deux propositions de stages par boutique
il n'y a donc jamais plus de deux
stagiaires par boutique mais d'après une
étude menée à l'époque par les syndicats
le secteur de l'habillement employait
seize mille stagiaires pour 95 mille
salariés soit 16% des effectifs de la
profession
deux ans plus tard nous avons voulu
savoir si ce recours massif aux
stagiaires est toujours une réalité dans
le prêt-à-porter sur internet
nous avons repéré une enseigne qui
recrutent de nombreux stagiaires une de
nos journalistes s'est fait passer pour
une étudiante en bts commercial
elle a postulé pour un stage de trois
mois on ne lui a même pas demandé son cv
la seule chose qui intéresse la
responsable du magasin c'est qu'elle
accepte de renoncer à son indemnité de
stage
bonjour je suis la jeune fille qui est
passé maître 10 pour un point stage oui
j'aimerais bien commencé vendredi avec
vous c'est possible vous avez la
convention jamais reprendre
d'accord vous avez la convention demande
renouvelle et je vous prends n'importe
quel jeu reprend
une telle convention de stage est
illégale au delà de deux mois
l'indemnité est obligatoire le magasin
se situe en région parisienne nous
sommes hors période des soldes mais nous
allons très vite constaté qu'il emploie
déjà de très nombreux stagiaires
bonjour je me présente je suis la
nouvelle stagiaire et je m'appelle
l'amia ouais vous êtes tout stagiaire
d'accord bonjour la bien on chantait
bonjour la mien ok on chantait vous êtes
stagiaires aussi d'accord ouais ben où
je crois qu'on est si c'est agir
aujourd'hui à quatre de plus ah oui en
fait il ya plus de stagiaires que
d'employer ce magasin n'indemnise aucun
de ses stagiaires
la plupart sont en lycée professionnel
et ont en moyenne 18 ans
ce jour là ils sont huit stagiaires pour
trois salariés seulement
et notre journaliste n'a pas encore
rencontré tout le monde bonjour bonjour
monsieur lamia jeu s'agir aussi à
chanter vous êtes ceci stagiaires
d'accord on chantait c'est le patron
d'accor ok bon oui ça va ça se passe
bien c'est mon premier jour de stage
l'homme possède deux magasins à cette
enseigne
il ne se cache pas de profiter de cette
main d'oeuvre gratuite
les dix stagiaires ezio ici j'en ai eu
11 sur le président lui aussi et c'est
exactement ça devant ces gens là pour
qu'on puisse dans cette enseigne de mode
à bas prix le travail ne manque pas et
qui dit travail dit cadence à respecter
je vais faire quoi cent cinquante pièces
en une heure vous donnez pas de g
qu'il s'agisse de poser les antivols sur
les vêtements ou de les ranger sur les
cintres les tâches confiées au stagiaire
sont répétitives
pendant toute la matinée notre
journaliste va ramasser les vêtements au
sol et les remettre en rayon
pendant ce temps ses collègues
stagiaires débat les livraisons le
patron a vu des sacs vides traînent par
terre
tous les stagiaires sont convoqués pour
une mise au point capacité de travailler
comme on sourit on verra sa première moi
je n'ai pas forcé à venir vers moi
devenu commun si c'est pas de la
garderie on à la mairie
le travail opéré par les boues
aujourd'hui ça va ça va aujourd'hui je
sais quoi mais là on ramasse tous là
pour cette affaire c'est le monde ou
encore docteur une stagiaire a pris la
parole face aux patrons il n'a pas du
tout apprécié nous ne la reverront plus
quelques minutes plus tard nous
apprenons que la jeune lycéenne a été
prié de quitter le magasin
la vie reste la dynamo il a viré là tout
de suite
ouais
moi je m'embarque prestation il retrouve
ce soir si ces chiens dans les faits
personne ne démissionnera de ce stage
ils en ont tous besoin pour valider leur
année scolaire
huit stagiaires pour seulement trois
salariés la boutique pourrait-elle
tourner sans l'aide gratuite de ses
jeunes recrues
sommes nous dans un cas de figure
habituel le patron parti nous tentons
d'obtenir des réponses auprès de la
responsable du magasin et je me dis à
beaucoup de travail en fait pourquoi ne
prenez pas d'employés en fait plutôt que
des stagiaires
enfin il ya plein de gens au pôle emploi
comment ça c'est qu'il n'embauche pas
quoi un éclat de rire en guise de
réponse
nous insistons et nous finissons par en
apprendre un peu plus
je me dis bien été engagées mais mon
patron m'a dit ah on en était on
n'embauche pas son cas le chiffre a
coiffé la crise financière autrement dit
la crise expliquerait donc un tel
recours aux stagiaires
cette enseigne affiche pourtant un
chiffre d'affaires d'un milliard d'euros
sur son site internet
nous avons contacté la marque quand nous
expliquons la situation service
communication notre interlocutrice
semble tomber des nues ça m'a interpellé
de voir que qu'un magasin fonctionner
avec me stagiaires et trois salariés
gelé un magasin qui est en train de
préparer en région parisienne par
exemple
effectivement sur une période de
préparation particulière la concurrence
était pas du tout en période de soldes
justement compreniez que on va pas venir
comme ont pris un sac qui pour nous
n'est pas la reine pélagie l'entreprise
en question
malgré nos deux mondes la marque ne nous
accordera pas d'interviews filmées sur
ce sujet les stages à répétition les
stages qui ne débouchent sur rien
concernent le plus souvent les jeunes
qui ont les cv les moins riches pourtant
même un diplôme bac + 5 ne met pas
forcément à l'abri des mauvaises
expériences
c'est le cas de baptiste 21 ans le jeune
homme est étudiant à sup de co reims une
des dix meilleures écoles de commerce de
france
il est venu s'installer à paris pour
faire son stage de fin d'études
eh ben je devais rester six mois sauf
que là ça fait trois mois et demi je
suis à paris je dois repartir parce que
mon sachet tout prévu
tout avait pourtant bien commencé son
stage dans la capitale étaient rémunérés
900 euros par mois et il avait pu se
payer une petite chambre dans ce foyer
du xviie arrondissement
voici le genre d'évènements que son
entreprise organise nous avons récupéré
ces images sur son site internet
des soirées professionnelles de standing
dans des hôtels de luxe
baptiste pensait participer à leur
préparation mais il a très vite déchanté
et sur le papier donc c'est vraiment de
l'événementiel pur et dur de
l'organisation d'événements et quand je
me suis rentré dans l'entreprise s'est
rapidement ce que j'ai fait c'est de
limeil ling appel téléphonique de la
base de données assez peu en rapport
avec l'événementiel mais plutôt les
travaux de secrétariat
tous les stagiaires même bac + 5 était
cantonné à ses tâches aussi ingrate qui
est essentielle au fonctionnement de
l'entreprise
lors de mon arrivée
pour donner un ordre d'idée il y avait
quinze personnes dans le service 5 cdi
dix stagiaires
il fonctionne toujours comme ça et
stagiaires se renouvelle tous les six
mois
régulièrement on sert que c'est le poste
moi j'étais en tant que chargé
d'événementiel sont d'époque sont en
permanence occupés par des stagiaires
non c'est pas normal parce qu'un
stagiaire n'est pas censé occuper une
place permanente nous sommes rapidement
baptiste eux réclament des missions plus
intéressantes à ses responsables
refus catégorique il décide alors de
quitter son stage pour en trouver un
plus formateur ailleurs al annonce de
son départ
le directeur général de l'entreprise
intervient il voulait pas me laisser
partir du tout allant même jusqu'à
menacer de devoir verser des
dommages-intérêts encore je partirai en
théorie un étudiant n'a pas le droit
d'interrompre son stage sans l'accord de
l'entreprise mais dans les faits les
employeurs ne font jamais de difficultés
pourtant dans le cas de baptiste la
sphère dégénère l'étudiant secrètement
enregistré le dernier entretien avec son
patron qui le menacent ouvertement
obligations
la convention contrats de stage ces
trois jeunes risquent juriste doit nous
payer un préjudice que je justifiais par
tout ce que tu n'as pas pu faire alors
tu sais avant que le préjudice que jake
cody deuxième préjudice public te
renverser des 4000 euros je vais devoir
te factuel 4000 ans pour l'emplacement
et le coût de ce cdd entre autres
lorsqu'il m'a parlé du coup ne fait
qu'un cdd lui aurait coûté quatre mille
euros alors que moi j'aimerais coûtent
entre 900 enfin j'étais totalement
choqués parce que je me suis dit mais
comment peut-on reconnaître comme ça
cache que prendre un stagiaire ça coûte
moins cher quoi qu'il arrive car ces
décès ça veut dire ça peut confessé son
tort bon moi je suis j'espère que tu
comprendras que je serais passé mon
avenir professionnel mon diplôme avancer
cette invention je veux tu comprends pas
tout placement est totalement illégale
des corps voici fujio digne de ton école
certains super et pédagogique et je suis
plus pédagogique du super et je
l'appellerai personnellement au genre et
j aurais été appelés pour mettre un
petit peu de plomb texte d'accord tu
violes thé qu'on traite les engagements
tout je ferai tout pour tous n'est pas
ton diplôme après cet enregistrement
baptiste n'a plus jamais remis les pieds
dans l'entreprise son école a fait
pression pour mettre fin à son stage et
son ancien patron n'a jamais mis ses
menaces à exécution
finalement baptiste aura au moins appris
une chose de ce passage à paris quand on
est à leur faire très attention là on va
mettre les pieds ou qu'on se renseigne
auprès d'autres étudiants justement
parce que là encore j'ai pas eu vraiment
de retour de la miss entreprises là et
ça a paru tellement beau tout de suite
que j' ai conseillé les yeux fermés en
fait jamais
après cette mésaventure baptiste a
validé un stage de six mois dans
l'événementiel au luxembourg
il vient juste d'être diplômé il peut
désormais se lancer sur le marché du
travail
baptiste a peut-être joué de malchance
car pour les étudiants sortis des
meilleures écoles
les stages peuvent véritablement
déboucher sur un emploi
paris quartier de la défense à son siège
parisien
ernst and young un des leaders mondiaux
de l'audit et du conseil emploie plus de
2500 col blanc une armée d'avocats et
d'experts comptables dans lequel six
cents étudiants font chaque année leurs
premières armes
jacques pierre s est chargé du
recrutement de ces stagiaires et les
candidats ne manquent pas donc pourquoi
et ben voilà ça c'est là c'est la
moisson de la journée c'est l'ensemble
des des cv que nous avons reçus de ce
matin et puis il y en après midi
je sais pas compté mais il y en a deux
en avant entre cent et deux cents ans à
peu près le nombre de seniors se sont
tous les jours chaque année jacques
pires et son équipe et plus près de
15000 cv les meilleurs candidats sont
reçus individuellement et soumis à des
tests de logique dans cette entreprise
le choix des stagiaires n'est pas du
temps de perdu c'est un investissement
bonne partie des stagiaires vont ensuite
devenir des collaborateurs chez nous
donc être proposés des stages
intéressants et sélectionné deux très
bons stagiaires c'est
c'est beaucoup trop crédit pour nos et
surtout l'assurance pour un recrutement
de qualité dans un an dans deux ans dans
trois ans lorsque ces jeunes ont été
diplômés alors pour être sûr d'attirer
les plus prometteurs l'entreprise ne
lésine pas en stage ces étudiants tous
ceux recrutés dans les meilleures écoles
de commerce ou d'ingénieurs comme hec ou
polytechnique gagnante en moyenne 1500
euros par mois
c'est trois fois plus que l'indemnité de
stage minimum prévu par la loi
c'est les fans y ont vu une preuve
fanny 23 ans est étudiant ingénieur son
année de stage touche à sa fin sa
responsable veut lui parler de son
avenir
je voulais savoir si tu étais contente
de la mission ce que tu avais fait
système est ce que tu avais appris
ouais je suis satisfaite puisque donc la
mission qu'elle a quand même duré deux
mois devant notre caméra
la tutrice se lance dans une opération
de séduction la moiteur dans
l'équipement était toujours de bonne
humeur
si mais toujours beaucoup d'entrain dans
ce que tu fais et c'est avec toujours
souriante n'ont rien à se reprocher au
final on espère on espère que tu pourra
revenir parmi nous à la fin de tes
études étudiante dans une prestigieuse
école d'ingénieurs fanni fait la fine
bouche quand on lui parle d'une possible
embauche peut pas garantir à 100% parce
que perdre j'ai déjà dit il me reste
encore il me reste encore six mois
d'études et puis 6 mois stage après j'ai
pas vraiment grand chose à dire si ce
n'est qu'on aimerait bien que tu
reviennes après elle elle nous a déjà
séduite
fagner nous avait laissés vides
puisqu'elle est là donc maintenant c'est
à nous de le séduire pour qu'elle va y
revenir
l'entreprise a d'autres arguments à
faire valoir pour recruter ses meilleurs
stagiaires en cas d' embauche elle leur
promet de valider leur stage comme une
première année d'ancienneté
professionnels une perspective
exceptionnel pour des jeunes qui n'ont
même pas fini leur scolarité
quel âge j'ai 20 ans
on prend
vous allez tous revenir d'ailleurs après
votre stage moi c'est un stage de
dominer de césure mes études mais là
tout de suite assure je pense que oui
vraiment c'est une vraie chance pour
nous et on
moi je vais la saisir comme fagnes et
ses camarades ils sont de plus en plus
nombreux à miser sur les stages pour
pousser les portes des entreprises selon
le conseil économique et social
chaque année un million et demi de
jeunes recherchent un stage